this video exists for me to tell you
that I'm making a new series of quantum
mechanics videos again but it's been
over three years since I uploaded
introduction to quantum mechanics and
since then I've learned so much about
doing YouTube and read loads of feedback
in comments and I've also had the chance
to teach people quantum mechanics in
real life in a fair few context so I've
been wanting to remake that video and
the first four videos in that series
using my new knowledge for such a long
time a few months ago I decided to
finally do it and soon after I found out
that I got a video making grant from the
vlogbrothers which I am so so grateful
for because of it I was able to upgrade
my equipment and hopefully make a higher
quality video and now I'm finally just
about to finish that video it took so
long because I felt a lot of pressure to
make it perfect I did and redid every
part of this so many times in the end
it's very far from perfect but I decided
that I just needed to finish it already
and I learned a lot from the process
anyway so I'm happy I'm going to upload
that video tomorrow the link will be
here when that happens and basically I'd
really appreciate any feedback that you
have I'm also going to unlist a bunch of
my old videos that I think aren't very
good or will clash with this new series
but I'm gonna put links to all of them
in the description here anyway thank you
so much for being patient with me